>> So part of the point of looking at these two different kinds of concepts is
that depending on the different kinds of concepts we are dealing with right now,
you may come up with a different knowledge representation and
a different inference method. Let me explain.
Supposing we're dealing with concepts like Foo or Holiday or Inspirational.
Then the case-based reasoning method might be a very good method for
dealing with things of that kind. We may have experience with specific holidays,
but we cannot abstract them out into a concept with prototypical conditions.
On the other hand, if we were dealing with concepts like a right triangle or
a reptile, for which we can define necessary and sufficient conditions,
in that case there are alternative methods available that might be more suitable
then case-based reasoning. So instead of thinking in terms of one method that is
going to work for all conditions and all concepts, we might want to think in
terms of a array of methods, where each method is more or
less useful for different kind of conditions or different kind of concepts.
David, I am sure you recall mentally who was a Russian chemist who came up with
the basic notion of the chemical periodic table. I'm sure all the students in
the class know about the chemical periodic table, which organizes all
the elements according to certain properties like hydrogen, oxygen, calcium, and
so on. Now, Mendeleev came up with this notion of a chemical periodic table, and
in some sense what we're trying to do in this course is to build a similar kind
of periodic table, except that this is a periodic table of the elements of mind.
It's a periodic table of the basic fundamental elements that compose
intelligence. Instead of talking about elements and valances and atoms and
so on, what we are going to be talking about are methods and
representations. So it as if we are discovering the fundamental knowledge for
presentations and organizations and reasoning methods that go with it.
Case based reasoning was one. Reasoning method that went with certain kinds of
concepts that are hard to abstract and
into conditions, like typical conditions, are necessarily logical conditions.